oh what's up everybody this is Titan
this is Tyson what's up oh my son
continuing making the Aerospace
tutorials on the nlx 2500 that's right
doing some multiaxis surfacing Oh I
thought you know what let's just put the
camera just a quick one and just show a
quick look at the tool right the Harvey
3 from Canam metal the truck the
relationship it's just like coock boom
boom boom so
good it's about to get
crazy it's about to go
down it's about to go
down hey before we get started I just
want to invite you to hit that subscribe
button if you love what we're doing hit
the like button put the comments because
we're bringing the heat when it comes to
education and overall manufacturing
entertainment
boom invading your office make yourself
at home here oh man look at that look at
that
oh so what software is this is it Fusion
360 Fusion 360 we're also using power
Mill just so everybody know so there's
like a nice variety there you know when
actually doing the complicated jobs all
right so Fusion is making it happen oh
what is this is this the tool yep that's
a harvey 3 ball mill it's a km50 hydro
Force fer so then the km50 is the
attachment right so that kind of like
the capto but this is a ball lock and
it's it's just like super rigid and if
it crashes which it never happens but uh
it doesn't damage your whole turret and
just destroy everything right so
absolutely love this tooling so let me
ask you a couple questions so the
machine looks super clean and your
multiaxis surface and you're almost at
the end of your program making the
tutorials for Titans of CNC Academy
right yeah but you're taking a bigger
step over so what exactly are you doing
here so we roughed it all out on the
previous Op with the just used six flute
in Mill okay um now we're coming back
and I'm doing a semi-finish pass with a
ball mill leaving so on the first in
Mill we left 10th out per wall okay this
in Mill is leaving 4 out per wall and
then we're going to do one final finish
pass at the correct depth to make
everything nice perfect so like the the
endmill left 10,000 but it had some
decent size steps right the steps were
big it couldn't get into these curves
exactly so it left a bunch of big steps
so then you came back with a ball mill
to basically surface everything mhm
right and then what is that about 25,000
step over something like that 25,000
okay and then you left 4,000 per wall
and then you going to come back and just
kiss it oh so good what's the what's the
surfice foot 200 200 yep 3 per tooth 3
th000 awesome that's aggressive for one
of these tools right here that's
actually locked into a turret right oh
man man awesome and just to show
everybody like this part right here is
just legit right so Ty you're actually
programming the entire part yep and
you're documenting speeds and feeds
stepovers everything I have everything
so anyone can make this exactly Incan
now 625 all day all day so and we're
going to do 718 we're going to do
a286 hasteloy
monell we're just everything complicated
we're going to basically just like open
the door doors let the secrets out of
the box so that people can actually
compete and make a good living and get
paid right make all these Aerospace
Parts show our secrets show our secrets
it's good that's what it's about it's
about serving this industry and lifting
it up if we close it in a box then
nobody's going to see it and therefore
they're going to think we can't compete
here so let's open up the doors and get
our kids excited about it and actually
take our machinist and actually teach
them this trade in a way that they can
do high level stuff and get paid good
money right
boom boom thank you so much we're out